allora oggi è il 20 giugno sicura
me l'hanno detto perché se a 20 giugno
ma non importa il numero di importante è
quello che stiamo andando a fare perché
sto andando a registrare la linea nuova
se ci sono gli studi
come regista
ma allora praticamente adesso
conoscerete il produttore del pezzo cioè
quello che ha fatto la base diciamo e
poi registrerò appunto le voci io tutte
le volte che devo registrare mi sento
raffreddata mal di gola e stamattina
come da tradizione parti si sono fatte
le nazioni perché non sa perché strana
lo psicologico i nostri dove registrare
magicamente non mi sento molto bene a
livello di voce di fumenti per le
registrazioni
la canzone si chiama lontano da te è un
titolo che mi piace molto e chi non lo
sapesse sono una persona che vive volta
la notte perché la trovo molto
produttiva come momento visto che c'è
silenzio certo per sempre super
concentrata e tanti video le scritte
anche di notte quindi anche per chi
guarda la musica do il massimo in quella
fascia oraria ciò che facciamo der su e
adesso ricky sta finendo la base e poi
registrò le voci e io ti giuro che mi
sento veramente la voce bassissima e
rauca ma le voci nel senso che fa
immagine senso che adesso la data è
stata costruita su delle note audio che
ho tentato io e titolo agli effetti del
mattino ovviamente non la posso partire
presente la base molto forte e la mia
voce di nota audio un po più bassa
perché ovviamente non solo le voci
definitiva e quindi magari in certi
punti non è proprio precisa emozionante
non presa bene dalla prima dell'altro
purtroppo ogni volta che ci sono le voci
perché poi queste zone si chiamano le
voci definitive queste sono le questi
ritieni che ha sempre capito cioè si
paventa anche queste voci
qui invece un po di tensione nell'aria
però ogni volta che c'è tensione vado
anche faccio anche le cose bene perché
questo tempo questa spauracchio nicolas
cage però adesso per dirlo le
movimentate già chiesto quando diamo a
pranzo non è in che senso
[Musica]
andiamo a pranzo quando è appunto tutte
le foto 2 punti cioè questa sera quindi
nero pinto di vedere di essere i piu
solidi come inter e se ho fatto
ci avevo una melodia in testa e niente
mi sono messa lì ho buttato giù ma ti
giuro in in un'ora tutto il testo resto
poi lo chiederemo ovviamente salvo
dormiva mi sono svegliata al mattino ma
la percolazione ico ce l'abbiamo
ce l'ha
[Musica]
a dieci minuti così forza
la mamma mamma mamma mamma
[Musica]
mamma mamma mamma mamma
baraldi tema è caldo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
parla ovviamente di una storia d'amore
ma una strada more che per varie ragioni
non è ancora decollata l'idea mi è
venuta appunto pensando a tutte quelle
coppie quelle persone appunto innamorate
durante la la quarantena che avevano il
proprio amore diciamo a distanza in
questo caso in particolare io l'ho vista
come un non riuscire a trovarsi mai ci
sono appunto delle storie dove per
quanto ci sia a trazione voglia di stare
insieme per vari motivi per varie
ragioni non ci si riesce mai a non dico
incontrarsi ma ormai la mongrain zani
esatto ho mai posto giusto momento più
esatto ci si sfiora metaforicamente per
un pelo e quindi è un amore che vorrebbe
nascere magari a tutti i due lati ma per
paure per incomprensioni per qualsiasi
tipologia di di motivo non è ancora
arrivato appunto al ad esplodere i
redditi come si registra gallone
gustiamo perdere i cori parte poi cioè i
cori e tutte le armonie ti fanno una
volta che sia la esatto la principale
novità mai ed ultimamente sia le mie
amiche o comunque tanti di voi mi
scrivono appunto chiedo dei consigli
riguarda la vita sentimentale e c'è
questo c'è sempre questa paura da parte
di entrambi spesso la paura di buttarsi
e ok quindi si rimane sempre lì appesi
della serie ok non lo so riguarda le
storie riguarda tutte le storie vuol
dire che si interessa di me però perché
non fa quel passo in più però allo
stesso tempo magari io stessa non mi
butto ok quindi c'è questa situazione di
non abbiamo come paura di far sapere
all'altro quello che effettivamente
proviamo
le portiamo fuori
dai che sta raggiungendo anche salvo e
pausa pranzo ovviamente cosa stiamo
mangiando allora il menù del giorno in
cui ho registrato lontano per quanto
rigarda il canto è pizza al trancio di
pizza margherita e insalata fredda
quindi abbiamo orecchiette pomodorini e
rucola olive che sembrano più delle
prugne questo sia un lieve e pomodorini
allora ore 15 e 41 torniamo a registrare
ci andiamo di ritornello e poi facciamo
tutte le varie le varie voci chi mi
segue da più di un anno saprà che
appunto un anno fa è uscita alla mia io
primo singolo cumbia love che è una
canzone sempre latina reggaeton ma
totalmente in spagnolo
so che tanti di voi amano insomma il
fatto che io canti spagnolo è una delle
mie due lingue perché sono appunto mio
papà spagnolo mamma italiana quindi
parlo entrambe lingue e mi piace
tantissimo andare spagnolo vi piace la
musica latina questa volta visco
comunque la canzoni in spagnolo l'avevo
già fatto voluto fare un po un po nel
senso mi piaceva anche farvi sentire per
la prima volta una canzone mi sa
l'italiano quindi non ho voluto
abbandonare totalmente lo spagnolo
voluto tenere in alcune parti però
diciamo che in percentuale c'è un po più
di italiano e spero tantissimo che
insomma vi piaccia questo mix ritornello
da cantare la parte un po più difficile
perché quella che starà un po di più
quindi aveva una mezza idea di
abbassarla di tonalità di metodo
mezzotono però poi perdeva perché
comunque bello che ti fa ballare hai
capito e quello esatto e quindi
all'inizio di tenerla così facendo mi
sgolare un pò di più che di c era il
lavoro né minimo mari arrivati un po
lontano da te parla di
una ragazza che viaggia molto quindi
nella prima serata appunto questo
periodo quindi durante l'estate fa molti
viaggi è però non riesce a godersi
appieno queste vacanze non riesce a
godersi appieno il viaggio che può
essere sia la vacanza che la vita quindi
un po metaforica come cosa perché ha in
testa appunto una una persona loro si
cercano ma non si trovano mai ecco
stiamo recitando una parte fondamentale
del pezzo e cioè il por qué che c'è tra
il bre ritornelli quello che mi lancia
il ritornello quindi si svuota tutto
fuorché quindi un pour que importante
cioè ho pensato a una cosa che è
successo anche a me quando ero ragazzina
cioè magari avevo in testa il ragazzo
hicks conosciuto a maggio poi me ne
andavo in vacanza con le mie amiche
dovevo almeno avrei dovuto godermi
appieno le vacanze conosce un sacco di
ragazzi però alla fine chiodo tease
quindi qualsiasi cosa mi succedeva c'era
sempre quel pensiero che mi portava
verso quella persona e quando ti succeda
una roba del genere vuol dire che ci
deve andare a sbattere la testa c'è puoi
pensarci quanto vuoi poi cercarlo tra le
persone malattie quello che vuoi e
averlo
allora adesso stiamo per fare una di
quelle cose che mi prende un po male
fare è però è importante per noi
facciamo capire tutto il mondo che
questa canzone è di marina quindi
all'inizio della canzone di remo marina
come fuga
noi come gli imbarazzo e come lo
dobbiamo fare credo che questa canzone
possa rappresentare un po tutti perché
bene o male tutti noi abbiamo vissuto
una storia che poteva essere ma non è
stata oppure stiamo vivendo una storia
che vorremmo concretizzare ma per varie
ragioni sicurezza e quindi mi piace
anche lasciare questo finale
certo della serie chi lo sa se questi
due incontreranno come saprete
autobiografica rilascio lo scriverò è la
mia biografia che porta la scritta
cos'era forse può aprile credo maggio
poi c'è stato ovviamente il log da un ex
era durante il lock down e quindi ho
dovuto aspettare sommati gli studi di
registrazione tutto si riattivasse la
macchina della musica e quindi oggi
sabato giorno 22 in più sabato 20 giugno
la sto registrando e non so ancora
quando uscirà spero il prima possibile
quindi ho fatto di tutto sto facendo di
tutto per farla sentire prima possibile
perché sto un bacione e ci vediamo al
posto ciao marina
[Musica]